if global temperatures rise by two
degrees Celsius the chances of avoiding
a three degree increase is slim and
here's why
warmer seas absorb less carbon dioxide
so more accumulates in the atmosphere
this adds to the global warming which
caused the rising temperatures in the
first place nowhere is affected more
than the Amazon scientists say a two
degree rise will kill off up to 40% of
the rainforest huge amounts of carbon
are stored in the soil around double the
amount already in the atmosphere warmer
soil means dead vegetation rots more
quickly and more and more carbon is
released at a 3-degree increased plant
stop absorbing co2 enough carbon
building the atmosphere to raise
temperatures another one and a half
degrees by 2100 the planet is tipped
into runaway global warming in this
future hurricanes are much stronger
cities in Asia Australia and the
Southeast United States face destruction
a snow disappears from mountains cities
and farms around the world lose their
rivers and reservoirs run dry saltwater
creeps upstream and groundwater is
poisoned this tips food production into
an irreversible decline grain yields
declined by 10 percent for every degree
above 30 degrees Celsius as the land
dries up seas continue to rise all
low-lying areas suffer floods and the
Netherlands is torn apart by the North
Sea three million years ago when
temperatures were last in this range
there were no continental glaciers in
the northern hemisphere trees grew in
the Arctic the sea levels were 25 metres
higher
you